what are your thoughts on homeschooling
because we had a very uh
dicey conversation with houston that got
a lot of views on instagram houston is
very adamant about uh homeschooling what
are your thoughts on that okay so
what was dicey about it i'm curious what
what lecture he said something similar
to what you said where if you bring a
kid to public school you don't know what
they're teaching your kid you know the
values that they instill in your kid
yeah even private school he believes
that he could shape their viewpoints in
their mind uh to a way that he believes
is
i don't want to say correct but in a way
that's maybe different
from everyone else okay so what's
controversial about that a lot of people
believe that it was sheltering to the
child that they're not going to have the
social skills to develop and come to
their own thoughts and and experience
the real world because once they're out
there they're not going to be in that
environment where it's safe i'm happy i
was public schooled by the way i'm
public school as well so but but i'll
tell you this so let's talk about
sheltering you don't think you're
sheltered growing up
you don't think you and i were sheltered
to a certain degree yes and no
i mean think about it it's just compared
to what
but sheltering to me it's not even from
the standpoint of your parents
if you're living in america say you're
like you know how you go to i'll go to
alabama and i'm like you know at a place
doing a meeting and i'll go to a
restaurant
hey so
where'd you grow up at right here how
long you been here 28 years what was it
like growing up in alabama you know what
people will say
the famous line it's the only thing i
know
she was sheltered in alabama right we
are all in a sense sheltered in the city
we grew up in in the state we grew up in
and in the country we grew up in what
you think about iran is based on how the
countries sheltered you to believing
about iran right
what you believe about china or mexico
or brazil or canada everything is a form
of sheltering so there is risk and you
know everybody is a little bit afraid of
the wrong influence getting a hold of
you now eventually here's what happens
the sooner you teach values
later on if this kid wants to go sell
cocaine and go become a drug addict and
do whatever he wants to do or she wants
to do that part's on them you can't
teach the right values and principles
after 18. it's very hard it's not
received the same way as you teach it
early on so the sooner somebody teaches
you the right habits the sooner you have
an edge the later somebody teaches like
for example insurance industry
if i were to tell you haven't been in
this industry for 21 years that's going
to be 21 years september the people that
gave us the most problems when they came
in were people that came in who left
three other insurance companies and we
would sit there and look at and say why
are we having so many problems with
these guys well they brought bad habits
from another insurance company the
people that we train ourselves we have
the least amount of issues with because
they're learning how to sell the proper
way you know in mortgages and real
estate i don't know if you remember
mortgage and real estate in oh eight in
oh six
a phrase that was going viral was called
creative financing are you family with
creative finance okay so you know what
creative financing is
creative creative financing
isn't that when they you like use a
bunch of weird like terms and stuff no
so he knows what it is so creative
financing would be uh how much money you
made last year and you say eighty two
thousand dollars is that information to
no no no so say you want to get a loan
to buy a house right okay and i would
say to you don't worry about it we'll
make a fake uh 1099 that you made 220
last year and we'll put in the file
don't worry about it we'll make a fake
bank of america statement wow
that's crazy there was there was all of
that going on all over the place for
creating those oh six yeah a lot of guys
called ginger loans no income no job
yeah no income that's right basically
it's stated so you could say whatever
you want in the application and they're
just like all right
creative financing was a wink-wink
business model
those guys that got trained in creative
financing wherever they went to next
they brought those habits with them to
the next place if forgery was a normal
habit at that real estate office or
mortgage office you brought into
pharmaceutical sales you bought it in
digital media agency you brought it into
stocks you know it doesn't matter so
that habit continues this if there's a
reason why people hired people away from
jack welch there's a reason why
companies recruited people away from
xerox xerox was known for training their
sales people better than anybody else if
you got a guy away at 29 30 years old
away from xerox and his first job with
xerox you're doing backflips because
xerox was known for having the best
training if like i came from valleys
bally's was known for having the best
sales training out of everybody so guess
who want to recruited people from
valleys la fitness 24-hour fitness why
because we were the best trainers we
were trained the right way no
misrepresentation none of that stuff it
was the right way by from the top so
what's the moral the story he's right
homeschooling i want homeschool because
to me homeschooling not everybody makes
a good teacher where i'm gonna have the
time or the ability to have my wife
teach
teaching is not for everybody if you can
have somebody else do the job for
teaching it's great but i support the
idea of people wanting to do
homeschooling today because they're
scared of what's going on with the
marketplace what the kids are being fed
today that is a big risk today when you
have kids
you look at it from a different
perspective look guy asked me today's
security as the the guy that we all came
through here the 70 year old man up
there who
is from virginia went to world war he's
seven years i've been here for 50 years
him and i are having a conversation this
morning at 6 a.m when i'm checking out
the property we're talking about uh
schooling and stories about you know
what the school's like he says the same
thing he said look i wanted to have my
kids be in an environment where they're
learning a certain values and principles
you go to public nowadays somebody's
raising your kids it's a very very big
risk today a very big risk today very
different today than when i went to
school it's a very different risk today
so i fully understand it but if you
don't have the means you don't have the
choice you have to go through public
schools if you enjoyed this video i give
a keynote a few weeks ago in las vegas
specifically on the topic of cracking a
code to content creation if you've not
seen it click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]